[Music]
and religious app Muse oh you could like
pray to Jesus inside of your phone I was
just thinking like Instagram because
your honor religious me Oh the Holy
Bible is one of the like most download
or with their top apps in the App Store
I have it you do do you really I used to
have it the Holy Bible I did I used to
read the Bible to Isaac when he was a
little oh that was like our story so
your story when Abraham begat this
person begat this person he got this you
guys like the first paragraph of Genesis
one of those I don't know it is the
beginning of the time he's lame dudes
brother he was about three or four years
old and that was happening and she still
remembers so his day he big momma
remember used to read the Bible to me
I'm like dang I only did it a few times
how do you remember that would have been
dope if you read him the King James
Version oh yeah that's the one that's
like that which was like the eyes and a
bowels and that was the only Bible we
had and I would go to this Bible's youth
group thing and they all had like the
new ones and I'm like mine is not like
that I just that was so funny cause it
sounded like Robin Hood submitted by
Nike or adidas both adidas Diez remember
that song it's a sundry work or some
night do you guys not know he was a
knight oh my god you guys so to watch
this video on YouTube where it's this
guy who calls into a radio station and
then he says in Spanish is like hey can
you play that song is this one very well
cuz I'm Mike are those Reebok or Nike
and then he's like no what song he's
like wait are you talking of this song
about the song and it's like this is the
rhythm of the night Oh
oh yeah music video he goes into
footlocker and he's like green eggs you
guys haven't heard I am because finding
out the first time all right
a Christian version of Pokemon go game
has received approval from the Pope
about it you're not okay so you go
around and you catch the Holy Spirit
yeah JC go stands for Jesus Christ go
and so it's instead of catching pokémon
players have to roam the world and find
Catholic saints and other Bible
character at school and so they can join
their ventilation game do they fight
each other like they do in Boca Maria
there's no fighting instead of fighting
you know how I get to fight them they
just bless each other know what they do
is they give you some like a religious
quiz you have to pass these like quiz
questions and that's how they the state
the Saint will join your team that's
cool yeah so it looks like this series
is going on catching these Saints so the
first one they released was in Spanish
that's what I was just gonna say it
would be in Spanish or French so Oh true
or false
how many people did I bless in my
lifetime well the question so it says
hola soy Antipas yo-dee-hey a Campania
san paulo which translates to hi Antipas
I said come with me to San Pablo and
then you have to say if it's your own
bus so like
like anti-peace does no but peace is
possible to say but anyway so I guess
you say true/false and then they join
your team if you're right that's not our
question I'm sure I can answer that I
should don't know so then like you just
go around and then you collect you can
also collect bread and water like damn
we out here collecting bread baby
that'll be dope it is the body of Christ
you're right thank you
that'll be dope it for like Jesus is
like the hardest character to find and
get like Pikachu Pikachu or like it was
hard I wasn't hard but it was the like
was it chars or it was like water one
there was a water one that was really
hard to find what the focus or not Volvo
yeah I don't know I did my Pokemon you
surround [ __ ] I think this side of the
room where like I'm like one foot in one
foot how you know Allah you're on that
side
Isaac never got in a book the most uh he
did like the pokemon cards he did have a
little fades where he was like
collecting cards of his friends I wash
that [ __ ] when I came home from school
for you cooking I was in high school
[Laughter]
were you on drugs there was nothing on
TV I just feel like Pokemon was so
popular when I was like in elementary
like yeah so I feel like it was like in
Mexico it was like of the devil like you
shouldn't play I went to a Catholic
school yeah yeah I went to a Catholic
school so like they would tell us like
oh the devil communicates with you
through the Pokemon how the Japanese
came on [ __ ] morning even though that
a kid is [ __ ] yeah yeah I really Q Euler
is the devil
any distractions right maybe that's what
I mean a Christian everything is so
devil yeah exactly
they had to so the reason why they
created this was in preparation or it is
in preparation for World Youth Day to
2019
so it's this Catholic youth event taking
place in Panama
January so they're just trying to get
the youth to really love Jesus that's
tight
and the religion Jesus College JC no
they try to make it fun yeah fun
you know what made you know what made
Church fun though is the music yeah the
singing and the dancing yeah won't make
Church fun for me in the food you guys
won't got praise they have hymns we're
like oh we're in Catholic school well I
went to like kids Catholic school so
yeah we did have music yeah I grew up in
a us folk hmm but when you go to service
though its traditional as hell right
yeah there's no music
I have to tell mi sorry cuz it's like
okay stand up cuz it's all in Spanish
understand I'm I know we got a Neil I'm
like I'm in you Stacy's we're a [ __ ] I
grew up in a Buddhist temple let me get
this down we just kneel for four hours
straight yeah this is this is really
looking out for you I was like
apologizing for all this a [ __ ] in a
holy place in your head with y'all
I just learned a new word I like this
should be thinking that mama bear bit
Buddhist temples I kneel for like four
hours straight do Buddhist temples
didn't even evolve
that shit's boring ass oh they see this
is all the way over you and your [ __ ]
bowing down to touching their head to
the floor we're talking about this [ __ ]
and I'm I have to yawn like non-stop
every time I go into it
yes possess like how the devil do guys
like truth [ __ ] you know makes me sleepy
you're next
yeah it makes me sleepy too I know every
touch even it's comfortable in church
right now I'm like yawning I remember
like just going into sermon and like
taking naps and stuff and sleeping on my
mom hello there
that's cuz I didn't go to a Catholic
Church oh yeah Christian churches were
so much more fun it was like a home
sometimes my mom let me go to a
Christian Church instead of a Catholic
so my mom was Christian my dad's
Catholic I went to catechism and did the
Culver Communion and all that stuff
but sometimes my mom would let me go to
the Christian Church and it was so much
more coming up with Christians we would
always go to that church yeah and yeah
it was a lot more fun cuz they had like
a whole band hey coffee and they had
like biscuits and stuff there like food
oh yeah they actually have food yeah
that was cool didn't we have pot looks
so after church everybody brings their
food and we all just chow down and then
they let us play with the instruments so
that's with you hmm you know I found
kind of weird though so like I was
Catholic right growing up and stuff and
I had like a rosary and I would go to my
best friend's Church which is pushed in
and they were like oh why would you
bring a rosary here and I'm like but
still the same God like well cuz some
Christians don't like Catholicism cuz
they ran away from it right so they
think like that's corrupted and like
were the new school ones and it could be
just the kids are just stupid
they should all just be loved though I
know that's why I was so confused I'm
like it's not considered Christians to
you I think you were supposed to wear
the rosary yeah you know that was like
in my little like phase the toll-f baby
was like cool it or where the rosary I'm
sure I have a picture wearing a robe
you're not supposed to wear the rosary
like a necklace yeah oh you're supposed
to pray with it yeah a lot of them they
don't it's not even big enough like to
go over your head I think the reason
though is because in Christian Church
they only pray to God and I named
Catholics have a bunch of the saints are
you paying that was really weird too cuz
it sounds like you should not prove an
idol but then there's like so many idols
and what about American false idol
American organic oxen they're so
greatest
[Laughter]
you can't have like a personal
relationship with God you had to like
say your sins to a priest and then he
forgives you through God it's like why
coming kind of closer sometimes like a
lot of things people have always wanted
to you know in the movies you're through
the confession you wanted to do and you
do it let's go through a screen creepy I
mean you're like staring at it yeah but
in the boot in the movies it's always
like the guys like this you know it's so
that they could cheat to the camera yeah
oh is that what it's for
but I always wanted to do that song I
wish I could tell someone
some secrets creepy ass Bob give me
never been in one of those like creepy
no wait what about confession so the
only confession I ever did was when I
went to Catholic school for just one
semester and they made me confess did
you tell them some secrets no I said it
was like well I've been a bad sister cuz
I yell at my brother a lot yeah but I
don't walk into a room think like a
closet looking for nothing it was face
it here just if I did that water you
know just like this no they didn't say
like that once
well what is your brother questions you
could choose if you want to do face to
face or the screen and like no one did
all the jobs did based I wanted to do
Catholic Communion because the pastor
puts a puts a little biscuit in your
mouth isn't a little it's like a it's
like those cones for the grade
yeah with less flavor with no flavor
yeah I just I wanted to be like a puppy
and I'm like I never had the wine really
give you real wine yeah we get Welch's
grape juice that's the that's the
traditional church watches grandpa
Christian when they had grape juice dads
yeah the Catholic one I have I always do
that [ __ ] when I go to your family stuff
what do you do like this right and they
put that in your mouth
well that means you don't want it I like
this not pull up mouths like oh so this
means that they'll put it on your hand
and then this is just to put int imagine
being the priest and being like okay
let's go everyone almost
and you don't even know do you know what
I mean uh no oh my it's the flesh of God
I just want to do it everyone are you
doing actually eating God right there
that's tight yeah and you're not even
supposed to do it if you've been sinning
yeah you wash each other's feet before
you do it no okay cuz we do what Oh
Buddhist no no like when we have our
communion it
oh you can't have the body of Christ
unless you've done first communion
yeah also I'm not even supposed to be
yeah you know I mean that's what you
want like this oh you have I thought
you've been always a he's a sweet kid I
thought my visa I'm eating good I'll eat
that shows what's delicious yeah it's
good let's go Neffe knows how to eat so
I'm like if this was gonna eat it that
means her nephew her nephew knows not
eat something I think I'll go to a
Catholic Church just to do the communion
yes I won't experience it go I want I
want to old man to feed me I don't think
there's anything if you've done like
communion ah is there something wrong
with it when I was letter they just like
engraved it in my head though you know
like yeah that's right I'm gonna do it
yeah yeah like all my cousin's got to do
it until I did my first communion like I
was so jealous cuz they all got to go up
and do it and I couldn't do it yeah yeah
I'm like I I don't know if I've Sam but
I'm just not gonna do it just thinking
you never thought like I want a snack No
[Music]